foreign
North Carolina and let's talk to Grace
what's up Grace
Hi how are you good how are you
rocking on since breakdown yes
very cool
all right well I'll dive into my
question if I had t-shirts you would get
one I don't have one but that was
awesome not yet not yet actually I'm
they're at the printer right now so
they're coming so what's up
well I need some help feeling like I
belong in my own home
why don't you feel like you belong in
your own home
well I feel like my kids and my family
are totally in love and enamored with my
husband as am I and I just feel
invisible like
not even there
which makes me withdraw even more and um
furthers the problem
so
why are you jealous of your husband what
does he do that you think you can't or
don't do
we are total opposites we grew up on the
opposite ends of the planet
um he is extroverted handsome outgoing
smart funny
talented
has a million friends
um successful and I none of those things
I call bullcrap on a stick in a box
on the wings of an eagle Grace you are
not telling the truth you are none of
those things you're not beautiful smart
fun kind engaging yes you are
well it doesn't feel that way sometimes
okay that'll buy but I won't buy that
none of that's true
um where does that story come from
um I guess that's always kind of been
the story I've never really like
excelled in anything I've never been
super successful at anything you nabbed
an incredible life partner
exactly
what do you do for a living
I work a as an admin part-time
so you keep the entire
one time uh I I was a part of
um an organization we had to make a a
lot like a million dollars worth of of
budget cuts and much of that was people
and on the way to uh my wife and I were
driving somewhere one day and my admin
at the time her name was Tracy she's one
of the most extraordinary people I've
ever met
and my wife turned on the radio and she
goes oh yeah I forgot to tell you and I
thought she was gonna tell me like um
she got a new pair of shoes and she goes
oh yeah I forgot to tell you
um if you cut Tracy I'm Gonna Leave You
I was like why and she goes because our
whole life is better because she is in
your life and so I don't care who you
have to cut she stays and I was like I
was like you got it so as an admin you
help people's families stay together and
businesses run like what
there's a picture in your mind about the
way things should be and there is a
feeling in your heart about the way
things will feel when we get there
tell me about this picture that you have
what is what is Grace winning look like
I feel like
um nope nope nope we'll get the feelings
in a second what does it look like okay
it looks like
um
me keeping a successful job for a long
period of time and contributing
to the home and being able to have
meaningful conversations with my kids
okay
um contributing to the home
that sounds like uh like a something
somebody stencils onto a like a
I don't know shiplap that's pulled out
of an old home and then they sell it on
Pinterest what is contributing to the
home mean
you pay bills you buy the nice like what
does it mean
yeah it's
it's we're to and from school on time
um and right now he does the majority of
that okay and on top of all of his other
things that he has going on where are
where are you in the home why aren't you
taking some of that off uh why aren't
you all sharing more of that
um I try but he you know the kids would
rather
dad take them to school and dad picked
them up from school and would rather be
around dad and so
I'm just home
why have you outsourced your feelings in
the operation of your home to
a couple of knuckleheaded kids
yeah I
think you've outsourced your entire
feelings to people that we as a society
said they can't even buy beer or guns or
cigarettes because they're kids
yeah they can't drive
because they're kids but you've
outsourced everything to them why
they're my whole world I want to be like
that Grace they can't be your whole
world
because they throw temper tantrums and
they say mean things
and they talk back and they forget crap
and they steal and they lie because
they're kids and they're just trying to
test how the world works
okay
who told you you're worth so little
I guess nobody ever really told me I was
worth much that's fair
actually in the trauma literature
um that's been one of the revelations of
the last couple of decades is that
trauma can be somebody doing things to
you they shouldn't have trauma can also
be withholding things from you that they
should have given you
and whatever it's worth I'm sorry
can I ask you a question about Mr
Wonderful
uh-huh
my guess is he contributes to that
is that fair
um
yes and no tell me more he has he has a
lot going on I mean he don't I I don't
give a crap I could care less
does he contribute to that
because the things he's got going on are
things he's choosing to do
and if he's choosing a lot going on over
making sure his marriage is tightly
braided together with you
making sure that you come first and then
those knuckle-headed slobbery kids
making sure that you've got role and
purpose the same as he's got role and
purpose it's easy to be a rock star
it's hard to set the stage up and take
it down every day
is he contributing to this
because my guess is you've idolized
somebody that's not an idol
foreign
and you've demonized somebody who's not
a demon and now you've created an entire
fantasy world with which you can't live
in and that goes back to this I don't
feel like I belong in my own home
because you've created a Marvel
character that you share a bed with and
he's not he might be good looking and he
might be funny
he's not perfect
and if he's putting a kids above you
he's hurting his wife
and he's hurting his kids
and he's using his kids to prop up his
own fragile ego and I could go on and on
and on and on
okay
my question for you though is do you
want this to be different because this
has been a pattern for a long long time
in your life right
yes
do you want it to be different
absolutely how much so because it's
going to upturn the apple cart
I mean it's it's got to go differently I
can't I can't keep going like this
awesome that I mean that's perfect that
that's somebody who knows this apple
cart is going to crash or we're going to
change directions right
foreign
something happened for you to call me
this is the moment hold on how long have
y'all been married
uh to be 16 years in December yep okay
um
how old are your kids
uh we have a 15 year old and a 12 year
old okay
[Music]
you've either thought about leaving
you have somebody that you kind of have
a crush on
or he does
no not even
positive
absolutely okay so why the call now
um I think I've been struggling a lot
with depression and it's that's honestly
what it sounds okay that's honestly what
it sounds like and here's the deal I was
pushing on him a little bit
Oz prodden the same as I just said I
think you've got somebody you might not
okay or I trust you that you don't
um he might have been over time picking
up the extra slack because he's trying
to love you the best he can
and if you're getting a little lower and
a little lower and he's picking up a
little more slack and a little more
slack you see how that's
self-reinforcing
think of it this way that's exactly the
crafting you ever um you ever and if I
talk to him he'd be like dude man my
wife's struggling I'm trying to give her
a break
um and so if you think about going to
the gym you ever I don't know if you
ever lifted weights have you ever seen
been to the gym and they got spotters
um
if somebody keeps struggling with the
weight and the spotter keeps helping
more and more and more
over time those workouts become
completely unhelpful
and the person who's getting stronger is
actually the spotter not the person
who's just having their weight supported
with by somebody else's work and so the
unfortunate thing is when you start
getting lower and lower the path out is
to systematically participate a little
bit more and more little wins
all right okay
you have to commit to decoupling
yourself from how you feel and reality
because your feelings aren't telling you
the truth anymore
okay
okay is that do you believe that
yes
um I keep this you if you're watching on
YouTube I keep this little thing with me
at all times I write notes in it during
the show I write notes in it while I'm
driving which I shouldn't do I write
notes while I'm hunting I keep this
thing with me all the time
for this very reason
you suck at being a dad
sometimes I'll write that down and I'll
look at it and then I can say is this
true I demand evidence from those
feelings
or I feel really sad
or I feel really heartbroken and I write
that down and it's true and I feel it
and I own it and then I go about what I
got to do next
and it feels like over time
your feelings have taken off and they
are now in control
and we have to put them back in the back
seat they are very important
participants in this ride we're on
but if we let them drive we end up in a
mess we end up out in the woods
somewhere instead of on the road okay
okay have you talked to a counselor a
professional
no I'm trying to
try to know okay
um I'll hook you up with a few months uh
with better help if you will commit to
doing that
absolutely that takes away your excuse
because they they can do it via Zoom is
that cool
yep okay
here's what I want you to start
personally though
I want you to spend some time I want you
to go to Walmart or some place you can
get on Amazon's order and have it
shipped to your house tomorrow
but I want you to get a journal of some
sort and begin to sort through here's
what I feel
have you ever sat down and said your
feelings out loud to your husband
um sometimes okay do you trust him
absolutely okay awesome so maybe do a
true or false test
I'm gonna rattle off 15 feelings will
you just say true or false that's it
that's all you get to say true or false
I am a burden in my own home he's gonna
say false
I am not funny I am ugly I am nobody
wants to hang out with me he's going to
say false false false
and we're gonna go down that list okay
when my feelings get very strong I
actually Outsource them
I've got a couple of people at work I've
got a couple of long-term friends that I
say hey I feel like this am I crazy
and they speak truth to me because I
don't see it my feelings are loud inside
my body and I know myself well enough to
know that now
um and I want you to begin to talk to
somebody and my promise to you is if
you'll commit to this the lights will
come on they'll be very dim at first but
they'll come on it's also going to
require you to do some things a little
bit different like
I'm taking the kids to school three days
a week now
whether they kick or scream or what I
don't care I'm gonna take them and you
might have to you know what hey stay on
the line also uh Jenna let's get her all
the questions for humans cards
we're going to give you some tools to
talk to your kids while you're in the
car with them because now it feels weird
right you feel like you're taxing around
people who don't like you
exactly
they do
it's just they're responding to your
weird by being weird and then you're
responding to their weird which they're
15 and 12 they're weird trust me
um if they're wearing new underwear
they're still weird right
um
I want you to begin to lean into uh
I suck when I said they wear new
underwear 15 and 12 year olds sometimes
shower and they put the same underwear
back on
if you've ever been to like uh camp or
something with kids it's disgusting
because they just are like what I gotta
change underwear why it's all fun that's
what I'm talking about
um
but you see how you're Outsourcing your
feelings to them so here's what we're
gonna do we're going to be the adult and
we're going to start practicing entering
square into their space
away I do this now is like my 12 year
old son and I uh we go to breakfast
every week at Waffle House
the uh the uh healthiest place on Earth
we love it
um my daughter and I a couple of nights
a week she is she is fused to my wife
and if I ask her hey uh can I do bedtime
tonight and read your stories
no Mom
and so two or three nights a week a
couple nights a week
um she doesn't get an option Dad's doing
bedtime tonight you can have nobody or
you can choose that
and if I trust me I feel like a like am
I so bad that my daughter won't let me
read her story like what but I also know
that she's six and she doesn't get a
vote into my innermost uh feelings
because she's six
is that fair
absolutely okay
hear me say this
you're worth being well
and your worth of marriage is incredible
that you feel an equal part of and
you and your husband and your kids need
you
to firmly plant your feet in your home
and say this is my home too
you can't earn your way to that it has
to be an identity that you act your way
out of
I am going to fill in the blank because
this is my house
I'm going to turn my dance music on and
we're going to dance
because it's my house
tonight we're having this because it's
my house
I'm doing bedtime tonight I'm taking the
kids to school because I'm going to
participate in the life of my home
because this is my life too does that
sound good
yeah
you sound like you don't believe me yeah
I'm sorry
in a process no it's a lot it's a lot is
this exciting or no or does it just feel
overwhelming
it feels very overwhelming how come
um
I don't even know
I feel like I've wasted too much time
and now it's going to be too late by the
time I turn it around all right you just
said it perfectly
I feel like I've wasted too much time
and it's going to be too late
I want you to write that one down
and I want you to hold it at arm's
length and be objective
have you truly wasted too much time
as a guy who's seen a number of adult uh
parent-child relationships change
dramatically into some extraordinary
relationships
the answer is no
you haven't waited too long
is it too late absolutely not
do you need to learn some new skills for
sure
do you need to learn a regular practice
of challenging those feelings absolutely
foreign
it's about a set of skills not that
you're a bad mom it's about a set of
skills not that you're a bad wife
is that true
you're right
Grace I know that so that's that's all
right fine you're right okay
you can't quit this conversation
okay well okay fine fine we'll just uh
we'll just do whatever y'all want to do
that's cool
now tonight we're having Burgers because
I'm freaking gracing I want burgers
see what I'm saying
now as soon as we get off the phone
you're gonna be go and go right back to
where where you're feeling
that's why I'm going to send you these
tools
um I'm also going to send you on your
pass change your future I'll send you
the book too I'm gonna send you
everything I got okay
great thank you okay
um please though at the top of the list
get a journal
and right after that
I want you to make sure you plug in with
a professional counselor because I do
think you're running pretty low and I
think it's been that way for a long time
Fair
yes okay let's get with somebody who's
gonna walk with you on a you know every
other day or a weekly basis for a while
and
um
help untangle some of this stuff
my promise is if you will put the work
in even when you're tired and it feels
futile right now it feels like it's it's
too too too too far gone
it's not
it's not
there's light on the other side of this
I've seen it
and you can see it too